francisca muy buenas noches y cuéntenos
qué son exactamente las perseidas
hola andrés buenas noches muchas gracias
por la invitación te cuento que las
perseidas refiere a una lluvia de
estrellas es decir estrellas fugaces que
podríamos disfrutar como dices tú
durante agosto en realidad es del 16 de
julio que estamos viendo estos brillos
en el cielo y se llaman perseidas porque
están sobre la constelación de perseo
a los astrónomos separamos el cielo en
secciones y en esa sección donde está la
constelación de perseo podríamos ver
estas estrellas fugaces y por lo tanto
todos esos eventos que veamos que se
llaman científicamente meteoros si ya
son están ligadas a esta lluvia la
perlas perseidas ahora como dices tú
también se ven en el hemisferio norte no
es la lluvia más fuerte que tenemos pero
sí considerando que será en agosto y que
tiene un buen tiempo en el hemisferio
norte se pueden disfrutar y es la
invitación es a disfrutarla sobre todo
ahora que tenemos noche sin luna
francisca porque este fenómeno siempre
ocurre en agosto
ocurre en agosto porque este tipo de
fenómeno se produce cuando nuestro
planeta en su camino en torno al sol se
encuentra basura espacial esta basura
espacial proviene de cometas que también
están orbitando en torno al sol y estos
cometas en su paso dejan parte de rocas
pequeñas y cuando nosotros pasamos una
vez al año por el mismo lugar en torno
al sol nos encontramos de nuevo esta
basura que dejaron los cometas que
podrían haber sido hace mucho tiempo los
cometas tienen ciclos en torno al sol
mucho más largos pero ahí queda la
basura y cada vez que pasamos por ahí
estas rocas pueden entrar a nuestra
atmósfera y una vez que se queman en la
atmósfera por las altas velocidades 59
kilómetros por segundo en este caso
vemos este brillo en el cielo y ahora
que tienen noches claras y con buen
tiempo en el hemisferio norte se pueden
disfrutar bastante bien pero lado el
hemisferio sur es muy poco lo que
podríamos ver porque estaría muy bajo en
el horizonte
francisca cuando hablamos de lluvia de
meteoritos también surgen dudas sobre si
estos fenómenos pueden ser peligrosos
que nos puede decir al respecto
bueno te comento que muchas veces vemos
en prensa así como un gran asteroide
impactar a la tierra hay que tener harto
cuidado nosotros los científicos estamos
súper atentos a lo que está pasando
estamos súper atentos a intentar
identificar los caminos que tienen estas
grandes rocas del sistema solar como lo
son los asteroides y los cometas y
también estamos estudiando formas de
aprender a
desviar los por ejemplo en caso de que
tuviéramos un evento de peligrosidad de
todas maneras tenemos estudiado esto y
hasta ahora tenemos considerado que los
próximos 100 años no debiésemos tener un
evento de alta peligrosidad
comparable con por ejemplo lo que le
sucedió a los dinosaurios con ese gran
asteroide pero si en el caso de que
llegara a caer una roca importante no sé
del porte de una mesa puede afectar
fuertemente y destruir en una casa y
podría ser un poco complicado pero los
científicos estamos siempre atentos y
por ahora deberíamos estar tranquilos y
si algo así llegase a ocurrir nos
enteraríamos con tiempo
francisca se habla de que esta es una de
las lluvias más importantes del año
cada cuánto se producen estos fenómenos
tenemos distintas lluvias en el año esta
es la tercera más fuerte
pero también ocurren simultáneas por
ejemplo mientras está ocurriendo
perseidas también está ocurriendo delta
acuáridas que se puede ver acá en el
hemisferio sur así que tiene que tiene
relación con él
la órbita que lleva a la tierra y
ciertos lugares donde se va a ir
encontrando estas rocas